MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture,
I'd like you to have
a first connection
between particle physics
and the Lagrangian formalism.
In classical mechanics,
you have seen
that you can write down
the Lagrangian using
the kinetic and the potential
energy of a particle,
and from that derive
equations of motions.
In quantum field theory,
you can translate this idea
and derive Lagrangian densities.
It's beyond the
scope of this class
to do all the mechanics of this.
We'll visit this topic
later in the class
when we introduce the Higgs
mechanism, for example.
And we'll be a little
bit more systematic then.
I'm introducing the topic now
because it allows you to answer
one of the homework questions.
So you can just
follow this lecture
and then you should be able
to answer the first question
of the second p-set.
All right, so you just have
to trust me at this point
that you can write the
Lagrangian for a Dirac field,
or Lagrangian density for
a Dirac field this way.
One exercise would be
to use this and show
that from this Lagrangian you
can derive the Dirac equation
for a spinor field.
But that's not what
we're trying to do here.
You're trying to see
what's the effect is
of having this Lagrange density
being invariant or unchanged
under global symmetry.
So we are able to
rotate our spinor
field with a global phase.
And we will see
that the Lagrangian
doesn't change and the
consequence of this,
which is if we can.
This is exercising
Noether's theory.
There's an overarching
global symmetry.
And out of the symmetry follows
the conserved property--
in this case, the current.
All right, so we can
express the symmetry
with infinitesimal
phase transformation,
as shown here, for our fields
and for our adjunct fields.
For the field and
the derivatives,
then, you just
have to do the math
and we find those
expressions, which we can then
put back into our Lagrangian.
First of all, we
write the change
of our Lagrangian in this way.
And as we just have
seen the Lagrangian,
its invariant under
this transformation,
and therefore the
change is going to be 0.
So then we use this information
at this in the equations.
We find this very
complicated-looking set
of equations.
OK, so now we get this.
And then we can
rewrite the terms.
So this is already with
a vision of what we would
like to actually find later.
So if we now look at the
terms involving the derivative
with respect to du
mu of our spinor,
we can express this
equation as shown here.
And with that, we find
the next equation.
I only show this for the spinor
not for the adjunct spinor.
This looks exactly the same.
But you, however, find
in this part here,
this looks like
Euler-Lagrange equation.
And this part needs to be 0.
So we only have to worry about
this part of the equation,
and the same for
the adjunct field.
So this then leaves
this equation here
where we have i
epsilon, a derivative
of this part of the equation.
And something like this you have
seen before in our continuity
equation, something like this.
It's our continuity equation.
We discussed this in one
of the last recitation
session, which leads us
then to conserve currents.
And let's go one step further.
If we now identify this
part as our current,
we can then use the
partial derivatives
of our initial Lagrangian.
Now we're just calculating
those terms here.
And we find that our current,
our conserved current
is given by the adjunct
spinor, gamma mu spinor.
And so what we have just
seen-- and this is conserved,
so the derivative is 0--
have seen that we have
a Lagrangian density,
we have a global symmetry.
And out of that, we find that
the current is conserved.
So this is all I wanted to show
here in the homework set now.
We start from a
different Lagrangian.
So this is our Lagrangian
for a massive spin half
particle, which satisfies
the Dirac equation.
In the homework, we are
looking at a scalar particle,
a massive scalar particle.
And the exercise, however,
is very much the same.